I believe it's actually satanic and I
think it comes out of the Bible and it's
uh Genesis chapter 11 verse 9. and if
you flip that it's weird it's 9 11. but
in that it talks about the Tower of
Babel and and that Nimrod wanted to
build a kingdom to heaven to go kill God
and what God did is he made all the
tribes make it where they can
communicate like you know and so
everybody went out the winter you know
Separate Ways so what they're doing now
these people that worship the devil they
want to invert everything in the Bible
so what they're trying to do is they're
trying to reverse engineer nimrod's plan
and build a one world order so we're
under one rule one currency one system
so it's actually satanic I know that
sounds crazy you don't have to believe
in Devils to agree with him because I
don't believe in like Supernatural yeah
but I still think that he's right
because I don't believe it but they do
right yeah they do these people believe
these weird superstitions and I don't
know if all of them do I know that uh uh
Nancy Pelosi said she was a reptilian
this week let's see if she did type it
in type it in oh my gosh she said it
this week she said I'm cold blooded and
I'm reptilian